so far
we're talked about how to define the
prediction target
next we introduce the cohort
construction step
cohort construction is about defining
the study population
for a given prediction target there are
only a subset of patient that are
relevant among the whole patient
population
and they are the study population be
aware
often we may not be possible to obtain
data from everybody in the study
population
as a result the data set we studied is
only a subset of those study population
so the question is how do we define the
study population
there are two different axes to be
considered
one the vertical axis we have
prospective study versus retrospective
study
on the horizontal axis we have cohort
study versus case control study
depending on the combinations we have
four different options
prospective cohort study prospective
case control study
retrospective cohort study and
retrospective case control study
in a prospective study we first identify
the cohort of patients
then decide what information to collect
and how to collect them
then start the data collection in
contrast
in a retrospective study we first
identify the patient cohort from
existing data
for example past electronic health
records of patients
then retrieve all the data about the
cohort
in prospective study we identify the
cohort and collect the data from scratch
but in the retrospective study the data
set already exists
we just need to identify the right
subset and retrieve them
next let's talk about cohort study
in a cohort study the goal is to select
a group of patients who are exposed to a
particular risk
for example if we want to be in a
predictive model for predicting heart
failure readmission
here heart failure readmission means
heart failure patient after discharge
from the hospital
comes back again to the hospital due to
heart failure
in this case the cohort should contain
all the heart failure patients who
discharged from the hospital
because they can potentially be
readmitted after discharge
the key in cohort study is to define the
right inclusion and exclusion criteria
to figure out what patient to include
here's a visual illustration we start
with all patients
then we try to identify the relevant
patient for a particular risk
for example these three patients are
relevant for this risk
such as heart failure readmission then
we want to build a model to predict
the target risk in this case the cohort
contains both positive and negative
examples
for example patient with heart failure
readmission and patient without heart
failure readmission
all this relevant patient is a cohort in
this study
the other common study design is case
control study
in this design we try to identify two
sets of patient
namely cases and controls and we put
them together to construct the cohort
cases are patients with positive outcome
for example the patient who developed
the disease
controls are the patients with negative
outcomes
that is their healthy patients but
otherwise similar to the cases
for example they can have the same age
gender and visit the same clinics
the key here is to develop the matching
criteria between cases and controls
for example we want you to predict a
model of heart failure
then we identify a study population of
over fifty thousand patients
and we have four thousand six hundred
and forty four case patients
those are the patients who developed
heart failure
and we match them against a set of
control patients on age
gender and clinics and we end up with
forty five thousand control patients
notice that in this study we have a lot
fewer cases with heart failures than the
controls without heart failures
this is pretty typical because in a real
world scenario
patients with the specific disease
conditions are often harder to obtain
while there are a lot more patients
without that disease are available to
serve as a control
to summarize in a case control study we
first identify the cases
then try to match them to a set of
control patients
in a cohort study we'll identify all the
patients who are exposed to the risk
and the matching criteria are not
involved